[Musik]
hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live soll die Ukraine marschflug Körper
aus Deutschland bekommen und wenn unter
welchen Bedingungen das ist heute Thema
in unserer Sendung es ist eine
politische Debatte über die Sorge vor
sogenannten weiteren Eskalationsstufen
im Krieg den Russland gegen die Ukraine
führt auf der anderen Seite steht die
Sorge dass jeden Tag den dieser Krieg
dauert mehr Menschen sterben die Ukraine
wird täglich von russischen Raketen
getroffen auch immer öfter im Visier
Hotels und Aufenthaltsorte von
Hilfsorganisationen Mitarbeiter der
Vereinten Nationen oder uns Journalisten
so geschehen auch gestern unter anderem
wieder in saporisha mindestens ein
Mensch wurde bei dem Angriff auf dieses
Hotel getötet in dem Gebäude war auch
eine Kindertagesstätte untergebracht sie
schloss nur eine Stunde vor dem Raketen
Einschlag
mehrere Menschen wurden verletzt und es
sind perfide Angriffe auf Zivilisten
auch hier in diesem Video die Kinder
haben aktuell in der Ukraine
Sommerferien ein Tag mit der Familie bei
schönem Wetter wie ich hier gestern auch
in saporica beendet mit tödlichen
Raketen auf das Stadtzentrum
[Musik]
wir werden am Ende dieser Sendung live
in die Ukraine schalten und über die
aktuellen Ereignisse vor Ort sprechen
mit unserer Reporterin beginnen jetzt
hier mit der Taurus Diskussion und bei
mir ist Oberst ad Ralf Thiele erst
Präsident der Initiative eurodesfans
heute Abend unser Gast schön dass Sie da
sind hallo
vielleicht müssen wir noch mal alle
abholen die sich jetzt natürlich auch
nicht so gut auskennen was ist dieser
Marschflugkörper Taurus was kann der
eigentlich wenn Sie uns das zu Beginn
mal erklären könnten das wäre wichtig
im Grunde ist das ein kleines Flugzeug
ohne Pilot das macht das gleiche wofür
wir auch den Tornado ausgelegt haben
nämlich im Baumwipfelhöhe zum Ziel Rasen
damit ist das extrem schwer bekämpfbar
dass relativ großes wuchtiges
Ding ist 1 m breit durchmesser 5 m lang
kann man damit viel Sprengstoff
befördern man kann damit auch Härtung
befördern so dass man durch Bunker
verwendet durchbrechen kann und im
Grunde in einem gegnerischen
Befehlshaber die Bombe auf den
Schreibtisch legen kann auch 30 Meter
unter der Erde das sind schon ganz
enorme Dinge ansonsten ist ja als eine
Art viel zweckwaffe für viele Bedarfe
ausgelegt soll vor allen Dingen eben im
Niederland logistische Lager logistische
Wege oder eben Kommando Bunker zerstören
über eben diesen Taurus findet aktuell
eine Debatte in Deutschland statt eine
Diskussion eine politische Diskussion
sowohl Politiker aus den
Regierungsparteien als auch der CDU
fordern von Kanzler Scholz und dem
verteilungsverteidigungsministerium
Taurus Flugkörper aus Beständen der
Bundeswehr in die Ukraine zu liefern
aber es gibt auch kritische Stimmen zum
Beispiel aus der linken linken aber
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius der
äußerte sich zuletzt auch mit Bedenken
diese Läden auf der Hand so sagte er ein
Problem sei Zitat die besondere
Reichweite des Waffensystems von bis zu
500 km wir haben dazu einen Kommentar
bei uns im Stream ein User schreibt das
mit dem Reichweiten Limit ist wirklich
nur noch lächerlich hauptsache man
findet wieder irgendeinen Grund damit
man noch länger warten kann was würden
Sie sagen Herr Thiele sind die Bedenken
zurecht die da vom
Verteidigungsministerium geäußert werden
wir schleichen uns in diesem ganzen
Konflikt sukzessive im Grunde in eine
immer tiefere ja Einbindung in den
Konflikt hinein unsere Außenministerin
hatte das sicherlich nicht absichtlich
aber mal so gesagt wir sind ja unter uns
Westlern nicht im Krieg miteinander
sondern mit Russland de facto fällt es
eben tatsächlich schwer von dem Ausmaß
das Engagement zu gucken wie weit geht
es wie weit geht es eben tatsächlich
nicht und das ist jetzt einfach wieder
eine neue Qualität die hineinkommt hinzu
müsste man auch noch Einsatz sagen zu
präsenzellenz gehen denn vor wenigen
Tagen noch mal deutlich gemacht hat dass
er auch Russland selbst mit der
Waffenwirkung nicht aussparen möchte
sondern ganz gezielt auch wichtige
Städten Kommandozentrale andere
Beteiligte Ministerien des Krieges geben
wird also von daher ist die Sorge zu
haben dass man dann eben auch
Präzisionswaffen dieser Wucht sie
traurig hat dafür nutzen könnte
sicherlich nicht vollkommen unbegründet
und gleichzeitig gleichzeitig setzt
Russland diese regelmäßig solche
marschflowkörper ein also die eine Seite
die hat sie und die andere Seite hat sie
auch schon geliefert bekommen in dem
Falle jetzt nicht den Taurus aber wie
würde man diesen den dem entgegnen also
auf der einen Seite Bedenken auf der
anderen Seite die andere Kriegspartei
Russland setzt die ja regelmäßig ein
ja es ist schwierig also dieser Konflikt
ist ja zunächst erstmal einer den
Russland auf Ukraine hereingebrochen hat
durch den Überfall und wir hatten uns
dann anfangs darauf verständigt im
Westen und viele andere wenn in der Welt
die Ukraine bei der Verteidigung zu
unterstützen und dann kam irgendwann
eben die Note hinzu Russland im Grunde
so zu schädigen dass sie nicht mehr über
einen Nachbarn nehmen
überfallen können das oder einfallen
können dass das war sozusagen so eine
Diffusion in der Strategie was was macht
man da eigentlich in dem Augenblick wo
es nicht mehr nur um die Verteidigung
der Ukraine an für sich geht sind
natürlich auch die sicherheitstress
Interessen anderer betroffen also mit
der Europäischen Union viele andere
Länder und natürlich auch unsere eigenen
und wenn sie mal schauen beim zweiten
ist ja der Kanzler oder die Ministerin
darauf verpflichtet der Sicherheit der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu leben und
ihre prospezialität das heißt wir können
nicht einfach sagen keine braucht das
also schicken wir Ihnen was Sie wollen
sondern man muss immer prüfen eine
machen
hat das gegebenenfalls Auswirkungen auf
die Sicherheit ob das Wohlergehen
unserer Staatsbürger und deswegen ist
glaube ich jeder regierende gut beraten
da erstmal tiefgreifen darüber
nachzudenken bevor er sowas tut nun gibt
es wohl Gespräche mit dem Hersteller ob
die Reichweite von den Flugkörpern
begrenzt werden könnte der Spiegel hatte
berichtet unter bestimmten Bedingungen
sei die Bundesregierung bereit der
Ukraine Taurus zu liefern wir schauen
gemeinsam in einen Beitrag darüber von
Frank Buchwald
sieht unscheinbar aus diese Waffe aber
hat gewaltige Sprengkraft Taurus heißt
der Marschflugkörper die Bundeswehr hat
ihn die Ukraine möchte ihn Berlin aber
zögert vor allem weil Taurus auch
Gebiete in Russland selbst erreichen
kann zu gefährlich finden manche in
Berlin ich finde das verantwortungslos
ich finde die Eskalation muss beendet
werden und es muss alles getan werden
dass wir endlich zu einem
Waffenstillstand kommen die Union jedoch
widerspricht die Ukraine müsste auch die
Nachschubwege der russischen Truppen
abschneiden können viel wichtiger ist
dass die Ukraine verhältnismäßig die
Waffe einsetzt und keine zivilen Ziele
bekämpft aber russische
Versorgungslinien auf russischen
Gebieten ja selbstverständlich muss das
sein damit die russischen
Versorgungslinien abgeschnitten werden
überlegt wird nun die Taurus Lenkwaffen
in ihrer Reichweite zu begrenzen und
Moskau keinen Vorwand zu liefern
strategisch aber geht es längst um mehr
wenn Russland Erfolg haben wird oder
sollte bei diesem völkerrechtswidrigen
Angriff dann wird das nicht der letzte
Krieg in Europa sein und wenn wir in
Frieden und Freiheit in Zukunft leben
wollen müssen wir jetzt und heute
nachdem wir es oft versäumt haben der
Ukraine unterstützen Olaf Scholz heute
unterwegs in Hessen hält sich bisher
noch bedeckt der Kanzler aber weiß es
geht nicht alleine um das Schicksal der
Ukraine sondern langfristig auch um die
Sicherheit Europas
wir haben uns das vorzustellen könnte
man tatsächlich die Reichweite dieser
Flugkörper so einfach dann begrenzen und
das kann man dann im Nachhinein auch
nicht einfach wieder rückgängig machen
wie ist das
ja man kann sie begrenzen also das ist
das eine Thema das haben wir bei sehen
wir bei Skype und es ist Shadow beim der
britischen und der französischen
Variante auch dass man die begrenzen
kann das ist wahrscheinlich auch wieder
zu ändern das ist im Grunde können sich
das wie beim tunen für das Mopeds
vorstellen dass er nur 30 fahren soll
aber bei manchen eben bis zu 70
Stundenkilometer wieder schaffen also
solche Dinge kann man auch ändern etwas
komplexer ist es diese
Flugkörper fliegen ja wie ich das schon
sagte
hört dazu braucht man eigentlich so eine
Art Gelände Modell das in dem der den
Flughafen drin verankert ist das dann
eben auch gestattet so schnell und so
dicht am Boden trotzdem ungestört bis
zum Ziel zu kommen wenn man hier an
diesem Modell etwas ändert insbesondere
russische Gebiete ausspart ist dass wir
nicht schwierig wir müssen auf der
anderen Seite sehen die Ukraine auch
schon lange vor dem russischen Angriff
hochprofessionell was das Thema
IT angeht und hat sich jetzt auch im
Laufe dieses Krieges als extrem
innovativ gezeigt wie man modernste
Informationstechnologie anwenden kann
bezogen zur Verteidigung gegenüber den
Russen und natürlich auch bei den
Drohnen Angriffen bis nach Moskau selbst
also von daher wäre es naiv zu denken
dass sie das was wir jetzt als
Begrenzung in den Taurus einbauen dass
sie das nicht wieder überwinden können
wir sprechen gleich weiter auch über die
französischen britischen Flugkörper die
die Ukraine schon hat dann ist auch noch
mal Zeit für eure Fragen stellt die
gerne per Mail oder direkt in den
streamen und dann können wir die gleich
noch mal mit Obers ADrive Thiele
beantworten wir schalten jetzt aber
erstmal zu unserer Reporterin in die
Ukraine nach Odessa eine Brühl ist bei
uns hallo Anne schön dass du da bist
hallo Anne ist diese Meldung dass
Deutschland womöglich muss man ja ganz
klar sagen Taurus Flugkörper mit einer
ziehen Limitierung liefern könnte ist
das in der Ukraine angekommen und wenn
ja wie würde das aufgenommen
wenn man die ukrainischen Medien hier in
den letzten Tagen verfolgt hat dann
konnte man eigentlich den Eindruck
gewinnen dass diese Lieferung der Taurus
Marschflugkörper unmittelbar bevorstünde
ich hatte heute Gelegenheit mit der
stellvertretenden
Verteidigungsministerin Hanna Mahler zu
sprechen und sie hat gesagt natürlich
hofft die Ukraine auf diese Waffen es
gäbe auch Verhandlungen man brauche sie
vor allen Dingen um die russischen
Linien zu überwinden den Nachschub auch
zu unterbinden aber sie hat auch betont
im Hinblick auf die deutsche Diskussion
die Ukraine halten sich an
internationale Regeln und
internationales Recht sie führen diesen
Krieg nur auf ihrem Territorium nicht
auf dem Territorium anderer Länder und
bei
Waffenlieferungen in der Vergangenheit
ähm hätten das die Partner der Ukraine
die diese Waffen geliefert hätten auch
niemals in Zweifel gezogen
lassen lass uns auch sprechen über die
erneuten Angriffe wir haben ja am Anfang
der Sendung auch die unfassbaren Bilder
gesehen Angriffe erneut Tag und Nacht
auf mehrere Landesteile funktioniert das
was Russland damit natürlich auch
erreichen möchte wird die Bevölkerung
auch mürbe gemacht dadurch
heute morgen gab es wieder einen großen
landesweiten Luftalarm und mein Team und
ich wir sind seit der guten Woche hier
im Land und wir können mittlerweile gar
nicht mehr mitzählen und da sind
wirklich auch alle Regionen betroffen da
werden Ziele im ganzen Land getroffen
heute zum Beispiel auch in der Region
Ivano frankierst ganz im Westen der
Ukraine und das ist auch eine Gegend in
der viele Leute in die viele Leute quasi
flüchten weil sie glauben dass sie davor
vor russischen Bomben vor russischen
Drohnen besser geschützt sind was die
Menschen hier entsetzt ist auch das
immer wieder Helfer zum Ziel werden in
Hassan wo wir ja vor zwei Tagen waren da
wurde gestern in der Region einen
humanitärer Hilfspunkt getroffen da gab
es einen toten zwei Verletzte in den
sozialen Medien schockt hier ein Video
aus saporisha von dem Angriff gestern
Abend da sieht man Spielen der Kinder
auf einem Kinderspielplatz und oben
drüber die russische Rakete im Anflug
die dann ganz in der Nähe in diesem
Hotel einen schlägt und natürlich sind
die Menschen langsam mürbe und das ist
ja glaube ich auch das Ziel dieser
russischen Angriffe der kriegt ja der
dauerte fast schon anderthalb Jahre und
im Moment sieht es ja nicht danach aus
als ob die Ukraine rasch militärische
das ändern könnte
genau das Video dazu angesprochen hast
wir haben es am Anfang der Sendung
gezeigt unfassbare Bilder schon wieder
muss man natürlich sagen es gibt noch
eine andere aktuelle Meldung aus der
Ukraine die heute viele beschäftigt hat
worüber auch hier bei uns diskutiert
wird wurde lass uns noch darüber
sprechen wegen Korruptionsvorwürfen hat
Präsident silensky alle Leiter der für
die militärische Rekrutierung
zuständigen Regionalbüros entlassen was
ist da genau passiert
ja das ist eine drastische Maßnahme und
sie zeigt offenbar auch die Größe des
Problems das offen das hier in Odessa
eigentlich seinen Ausgang genommen hat
denn der Leiter des Rekrutierungsbüros
äh hier für die Region norddessa der
wurde bereits im Juni entlassen da gab
es
Bestechungsgelder in Millionen Höhe die
offenbar auch zum Kauf eines Hauses in
Spanien genutzt wurden
Präsident selenski hat heute allen alle
regionalen Leiter dieser
Rekrutierungsbüros entlassen er hat
gesagt und das zitiere ich jetzt im
Krieg sei bestächlichkeit
landesverath man muss ja wissen seit
Kriegsbeginn seit dem 24 Februar
vergangenen Jahres er gilt die mobil
machen für alle Männer zwischen 18 und
60 Jahre die wird alle 90 Tage
verlängert es gibt nur wenige Ausnahmen
natürlich Krankheit und Tauglichkeit
Familienväter mit mehr als drei Kindern
die sind im Moment auch noch ausgenommen
zu das Kriegs hat viele Freiwillige
gegeben die sich gemeldet haben aber
mittlerweile muss man sagen weiß
eigentlich jeder der in diesem Alter ist
dass wenn er als Soldat eingezogen wird
dass dass er mit mit schlimmem
konfrontiert dass die Verluste auch der
Ukrainer sind natürlich sehr hoch wenn
man hier durchs Land fährt über die
Friedhöfe dann sieht man schon von
weitem die Soldaten Gräber über denen
die ukrainische Flagge weht und dieser
Anzahl der Flaggen auf den Friedhöfen
die steigt eigentlich bei jedem Mal und
vielleicht eins noch und da schließt
sich so ein bisschen der Bogen äh also
Präsident selenski hat gestern Abend in
seiner Abend Ansprache noch mal seine
Ukraine dorthin genannt und an der er
noch arbeitet aber der Kernsatz dazu
heißt das Ziel ist das den Krieg zu
gewinnen ohne das Land zu verlieren und
das heißt wohl auch die Ukraine
muss Transparenz sein mit Rechten die
für alle gelten und in diesem
und und so ist dann auch diese Maßnahme
von heute zu verstehen
Eindrücke von einem Brühl live aus
Odessa für uns vielen Dank Anne
und bei uns jetzt wieder in der Sendung
Oberst ad Ralf Thiele jetzt auch für uns
hier da die User Fragen und sind viele
ich habe sie schon ein bisschen
gesammelt für uns zu beantworten wollen
wir damit direkt einsteigen wir haben
gerade eben die eindrücklichen
Schilderungen unserer Reporterin live
aus der Ukraine gehört dazu passt die
Frage von
wildeva ein User der wissen möchte warum
wird immer wieder von einer Eskalation
geredet russland hat doch schon maximal
eskaliert was hindert uns also daran
diese Waffe zu liefern um den Aggressor
zu schlagen
Eskalation wir nutzen im militärischen
Fachbereich auch im politischen gerne
das Bild eskalationsleiter man erkennt
dann daran dass es eben Sprossen gibt
die man hinaufsteigen kann in der
Eskalation ganz oben in diesen Sprotten
stehen im Grunde wenn man eine vertikale
Eskalation sich anschaut der Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen den haben wir ja Gott sei
Dank nicht also von daher sieht man dass
tatsächlich Spielraum ist nach oben was
das Thema Eskalation angeht es gibt auch
als zweites eine horizontale Eskalation
das heißt also das Gefechtsfeld weitet
sich aus von dem bisherigen kriegsraum
wesentlichen Ukraine und gelegentlich
einmal Ränder Russlands auf
Nachbarstaaten im Schwarzen Meer sehen
wir schon solche Dinge gesehen im
Kontext der Weizen Lieferung helfen an
der Donau da ist Rumänien schon
einigermaßen befasst auch die baltischen
Staaten und Polen sind alarmiert über
die Wagner präsen und die
Empfindlichkeit oben dieses Korridors
nach
Königsberg also man sagen es kann alles
viel schlimmer kommen und natürlich
könnte irgendwann am Ende dieser Skala
auch mal der Einsatz russischer Waffen
über oder in Deutschland sein dass alles
kann man nicht ausschließen und deswegen
ist in Politik gut beraten sorgsam zu
wägen welche Schritte sie
unternimmt damit eben diese Eskalation
die ich gerade beschrieben haben nicht
stattfinden die deutsche Politik wirkt
auch noch ab da sind andere schon
schneller gewesen Frankreich und
Großbritannien werden schon angesprochen
die liefern bereits lenkbare Raketen mit
großer Reichweite der User von eben der
schließt auch noch eine Frage an die
einige hier bei uns im Stream
beschäftigt und zwar fragt er sich warum
diese Zurückhaltung beim Taurus dieser
Marschflugkörper wurde in ähnlicher Art
schon von den Franzosen und Briten
geliefert das verstehen einige nicht
ja die Briten sind ja wie soll ich das
mal sagen ein bisschen Vorreiter so
ähnlich wie die Polen in diesem Konflikt
das heißt sie beide Nationen drängen
ganz besonders schnell die nächsten
Schritte zu unternehmen das ist eben wie
gesagt eine Eigenart die man hier sehen
kann generell ist der Gedanke Vorsicht
insbesondere für kriegsnationen auch wie
es Deutschland einmal war gerade auch
noch als Kriegs Verursacher tatsächlich
da etwas nachdenklich an die Schritte zu
gehen sicherlich angemessen Frankreich
versucht ja als eigenständiger
geopolitische Spieler immer auch eine
hervorgehobene Rolle zu spielen wir
Deutschen versuchen das bislang nicht
das steht uns im Grunde auch nicht
wirklich schlecht an wenn man jetzt mal
von dieser Helm Affäre am Anfang des
Ukraine Kriegs absetzen wo wir eben
meinten damit glänzen zu können dass wir
5000 Helme geliefert haben muss man ja
wirklich sagen Deutschland hat ja eine
ganz prominente Rolle gleich hinter den
USA was die Unterstützung der Ukraine
angeht wirtschaftlich finanziell aber
auch eben mit allen möglichen
militärischen Gütern also von daher
glaube ich müssen wir uns da nicht
wirklich hinter diesen beiden Ländern
Frankreich und Großbritannien verstecken
es gibt ein paar Kommentare im Streams
gibt nur so die Stimmung mal wieder die
sich schon auch an diesem diskutieren
und zögern in Deutschland stören so
schreibt Dave Albright bei Youtube für
Krieg gibt es keine Zeit zu diskutieren
wir müssen der Ukraine trauen und die
Waffen liefern Martin koschatke schreibt
per Mails die brotlosen Diskussionen um
die Lieferung der notwendigen Waffen für
die Ukraine ist ein Armutszeugnis für
unsere Regierung findet der User ein
Sieg der Ukraine ist offensichtlich
nicht erwünscht das schreibt er sonst
hätten die Verantwortlichen dies längst
als Ziel definiert aber bleiben wir auch
noch mal ein bisschen jetzt erst noch
mal beim Taurus selbst dazu gibt es
nämlich auch noch viele Fragen ob es
überhaupt vielleicht auch der Taurus
sein muss so fragt sich Chris gibt es
andere Waffensysteme ähnlich wie der
Taurus die liefer Bar wären in
entsprechender Stückzahl warum
diskutieren wir also über den den Taurus
jetzt
in der exzellente Frage man soll ja
fragen mich beantworten aber ich sag mal
trotzdem meine exzellente Frage warum
reden wir über den Taurus weil wir es
verschlafen haben die
munitionsproduktion der Waffen der
Artillerie Waffen anderer die die
Ukraine wirklich dringlich brauchen in
ihrem Kampf rechtzeitig anzuschieben wir
haben das also endlos lange verschlafen
während wir also ständig über Leos reden
und doch nach vorne schicken wollen
haben wir über die Logistik wie kann ich
das entstand halten und immer wieder
instand setzen wie kann ich die ganzen
Ersatzteile und auch die Munition dafür
auf den Weg bringen all das haben wir
verschlafen und deswegen ist die Ukraine
jetzt in einer Situation wo sie die Zeit
bis 19 bis 2024 überbrücken muss weil
erst dann diese Logistik erst richtig
loslegen und deswegen kommt eben immer
dieser Gedanke dann nehmen wir doch
lieber noch einen größeres noch ein
weitreichenderes Waffensystem und diesen
Mangel an Unterstützung der bisher
im stattfindet zu überbrücken also
deswegen es gäbe viele andere bessere
geeignete Sachen Systeme aber die haben
wir halt nicht und deswegen kommt in
dieser Gedanke wir nehmen dann
weitreichendere Waffensystem und wenn
wir dann darüber sprechen was der Taurus
kann denn auch dazu gibt es Fragen bei
uns im Stream so schreibt einen User
Userin mit dem Namen icke können die
deutschen Taurus Marschflugkörper
strategisch entscheidend sein und die
Kriegszeit zugunsten der Ukraine
erheblich verkürzen
das auch wieder eine Frage die mir sehr
zusagt warum in unserer Diskussion
vermischen wir ja immer diese wirklich
wichtigen Begriffe strategie-operation
und Taktik Strategie ist die Lehre vom
Gewinnen des Krieges also wenn jemand
sagt ist das ein strategisch bedeutsame
Wache dann heißt das kann die Ukraine
durch die Nutzung der Taurus den Krieg
gewinnen nein kann sie nicht sie hat
hier auf taktischer Ebene das sind die
Gefechte unten am Boden der rund um die
Front oder in operation das sind ein
großräumigere Bewegung dort kann sie
tatsächlich Punkte machen das gilt eben
genau an diesen Zielen gegnerische
Kommando Bunker also fehlstände außer
Gefecht zu setzen das heißt damit zu
vermeiden dass es gerade wichtig in der
russischen Kriegsführung die eine
befehlstaktische ist die von oben kommt
wo die Soldaten nur dass du tun dürfen
was grundsätzlich ihre Befehlshaber
sagen wenn ich also die Befehlshaber
bekämpfe dann können die Soldaten vorne
nicht mehr richtig kämpfen da hat das
durchaus an der Front in einer
taktischen oder auch in der operativen
Situation eine Bedeutung darüber hinaus
gibt es dann eben auch das ganze Thema
der Logistik wenn eben auch bei den
Bussen die Munition nicht ankommt oder
Verstärkung nicht ankommen dann können
Sie natürlich vorne auch nicht mehr
verteidigen denn das tun sie ja
offensichtlich derzeit außerordentlich
gut
und die Frage ist natürlich aber auch
wenn da kein Taurus geliefert wurde aber
Russland hat ja einiges entgegenzusetzen
wie schätzen Sie das denn ein also wenn
man jetzt dabei bliebe und einfach
keinen Taurus von deutscher Seite
liefern würde dann wäre doch das was
Russland auf der anderen Seite
entgegenzusetzen hätte schon eine ganze
Menge noch oder nicht
russland hat sehr sehr viel man muss
sich aber natürlich auch hier unsere
Rammstein Gruppe anschauen das ist diese
Gruppe diese ganze Versorgung für die
Ukraine Unternehmen ursprünglich waren
das mal ein paar amerikanische
oberstleuten an der mittlerweile zu sein
riesige Formation wieder zusammensetzt
und dann treffen sich immer wieder die
verteidigungsliste und das was
vorbereitet ist dann auch entsprechend
zu beschließen und was sie machen ist
die gucken genau was brauchen keine um
weiter erfolgreich sein zu können und da
stellt sich dann doch heraus dass
manches was öffentlich gefördert wird
nicht wirklich das trinkste ist was du
keine brauchst wir haben das gesehen bei
dem Thema Luftverteidigung tatsächlich
während also hier immer Leo gerufen
wurde brauchte die keine tatsächlichen
Verteidigung und die hat sich als
außerordentlich bedeutsam für die
Ukraine herausgestellt die
Luftverteidigung so etwas wird
tatsächlich ganz präzise im Detail mit
von ukrainischen
Befehlshabern und Verantwortlichen mit
NATO Befehlshabern Verantwortlichen
besprochen im Detail und dann wird eben
mit den Nationen verhandelt wer kann was
liefern wer hat was und er kann das wie
machen das ist tatsächlich sozusagen das
wirklich bedeutsame und darüber hinaus
wird dann immer gern mehr gefordert das
ist eben auch problematisch nehmen wir
mal das Beispiel Flugzeuge 16 ist ja
eins dieser Themen wenn man sich
anschaut wie viele Jahre bei uns Piloten
lernen müssen damit sie überhaupt diese
westlichen Waffensysteme fliegen können
und dann müssen sie immer noch in
Weiterbildung lernen wie man das Ganze
im Kampf Geschehen integriert mit
anderen
Landstreitkräften Weltraum Streitkräften
alle möglichen anderen zusammen so
orchestriert dass er seinen Sinn macht
dann ist eben das nicht tatsächlich sehr
sinnvoll schnell F 16 also westliche
Flugzeuge wieder hinzukommen dann diese
eine unglaubliche logistische Kette weil
das muss ja alles gewartet gepflegt
immer wieder einsatzbereit gemacht
werden weil das ist alles eben sehr sehr
komplex und deswegen hat dieses
Rammstein Format auch so etwas
Unsichtbares was wir täglich nicht sehen
aber diese diese ganzen Offiziere und
Offiziere die dort daran arbeiten wie
können wir die Ukraine am besten
versorgen die machen eigentlich die
kernarbeit in der Unterstützung jetzt
letzter Satz das nimmt aber natürlich
den politischen Verantwortlichen hier
nicht die Aufgabe Entscheidungen zu
treffen also dieses Trauerspiel zum
Beispiel dass wir so lange keine
Munition bestellt haben und dann uns bei
der Industrie beklagt haben dass sie
keine Produktionskapazitäten hat das war
ja unfassbar und das ist für die Ukraine
lebensgefährlich weil sie sind auch
solche Personen gewesen sie haben
westliche Flugzeuge und logistiken
Logistik angesprochen dazu gibt es eine
Frage von Thomas Berger bei Youtube er
möchte wissen lässt sich der Taurus ohne
Probleme unter ukrainische Flugzeuge bzw
der F16 Schnallen oder sind technische
Umrüstung notwendig
tatsächlich sind technische Adaptionen
bedeutsam wir können vermuten ich weiß
es jetzt allerdings auch nicht gewiss
dass die mit 21 zum Beispiel die
Bundeswehr mal geflogen hat also die
Luftwaffe geflogen hat dass sie soweit
auch westliche Standards getrennt sein
das ist da Schnittstellen gibt das ist
das Stichwort Schnittstellen das geht ja
neben der Befestigung der Taurus unter
dem Flugzeug dann eben darum dort eine
Schnittstelle zu haben weil die man
kommunizieren kann mit dem Körper Ziel
Laden geben kann bekämpfungsoption all
diese Dinge dass die dann eben
entsprechend eingegeben werden können
das geht wahrscheinlich mit nix die
westlichen Streitkräften geflogen sind
da gibt es ein paar davon ist geht
wahrscheinlich über kleine ab dazu mit
der F16 es gibt höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht mit dem Flugzeugen die die Ukraine
originären Bestand hat
und bleiben wir jetzt auch noch mal ganz
zum Schluss der Sendung jetzt auch noch
mal bei der aktuellen Diskussion und
Debatte weil auch dazu habe ich fragen
gesehen also es geht ja darum darüber
wird diskutiert so wir haben es am
Anfang schon gesagt das stand auf
unserem thumbnail es geht darum also im
womöglich Taurus zu liefern aber eben
mit einer zielbegrenzung dazu wollen wir
zum Schluss auf jeden Fall noch die
Frage von Gerhard Schrader Stellen der
möchte bei Youtube wissen was bringt
einen Reichweiten Limit wenn dadurch die
gegnerische Raketenstellung nicht
getroffen werden können also noch mal
ganz klar was bringt das reichweit was
würde das bringen
das Reichweiten Limit ist im Grunde ein
eine misstrauenserklärung gegenüber der
ukrainischen Führung diese ist natürlich
nicht ganzlich unbegründet wir sehen
dort sehr viele heißblütige Amtsträger
die wir wissen ja im Grunde dass diese
auch Terroranschläge in Moskau
unternommen haben
Mordanschläge auf Menschen die eben
Dinge gesagt haben die man in der
Ukraine nicht hören wollte es ist also
nicht ganz sicher was passiert
eigentlich damit mit solchen eisblütigen
Freundin die dann eben auch schon mal
dazu neigen den anderen bestrafen zu
wollen und da können wir uns ja dann aus
der Mitverantwortung auch nicht stehen
das heißt wenn wir dann gesagt haben
guten Glaubens wir haben es gegeben und
sie haben es falsch verstanden gemacht
dann tragen wir wenn man das nun
verantwortungsvideos betrachtet dafür
natürlich auch eine Mitverantwortung das
ist genau das Ringen um die Entscheidung
sollen wir das jetzt so drauf vertrauen
dass diese Begrenzung dann auch
tatsächlich so respektiert werden
eine Sache muss ich hier noch anfügen es
gibt eine Kritik aus dem Chat die will
ich Ihnen doch auch noch mitgeben und
sie auch darauf antworten lassen Thomas
Eichler der schreibt Herr Thiele ich
laufe dabei ihnen nicht mit verteidigen
heißt auch schlagen und manchmal muss
man erst zurückschlagen was würden Sie
Herr Thomas Eichler Antworten
aber das ist das Thema eben tatsächlich
auch für die Ukraine bei der Ukraine die
wird sich tapfer und sollte sich wie sie
das auch tun nicht nur auf eigenem Boden
wären also dass da kann ich das Thema
schlagen durchaus Sinn geben das Problem
dass ich für uns stellt ihr machen ja
praktisch die gesamte Kriegswirtschaft
für die Ukraine zumindest überwiegend
und deswegen sind wir implizit auch wenn
bürgerrechtlich nicht aber doch
irgendwie beteiligt an dem Thema und für
uns kommt im schlagen als
bürgerrechtlich nicht höchstpartei als
nicht Kommandant nicht in Frage für die
Ukraine ist das tatsächlich ganz ganz
wesentlich für den Erfolg ich darf das
vielleicht auch nur noch abschließen
dazu sagen auch für unsere Deutschland
als sie sich ebenso wertunion damals
verteidigen wollte bestand immer
gegenüber einer vorigen sowjetische
Streitmacht die Aufgabe darin durch
ständige kleine Angriffe diese
Streitmacht zum Stoppen zu bewegen und
dazu gehört nun auch Schläge in das
Hinterland also die disruption die der
Taurus machen kann aber noch einmal das
ist nicht unser Thema in Deutschland wir
unterstützen die Ukraine dabei sich zu
verteidigen wir sind nicht selbst
Kriegsparteien deswegen ist das Schlagen
nicht unser Thema es ist sehr wohl eine
Branche das sagt Oberst Adile der heute
Abend unser Gast war vielen Dank
und ich lese auch dass ihr dazu viele
Meinungen und Diskussionen habt gerne
auch natürlich möchte ich euch ermuntern
wie immer dass ihr auch gerne noch
weiter untereinander diskutieren könnt
im Chat wir für heute Abend sagen Danke
und wünschen euch ein schönes Wochenende
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss